a miles de fieles se reúnen en la gran
mezquita en la ciudad santa musulmana de
la meca para marcar el comienzo del
ramadán el festejo de un mes de duración
verá a más de 1500 millones de devotos
de todo el mundo ayunar desde el
amanecer hasta el atardecer su inicio
está determinado por el primer
avistamiento de la luna creciente sobre
la meca las autoridades religiosas
sauditas anunciaron que el mes sagrado
comenzaría el sábado tras el
avistamiento de la luna creciente una
costumbre que se sigue desde hace siglos
hoy gracias a dios hemos podido ver el
creciente de ramadán en el año hice
1.443 en el observatorio de tu maíz y
hemos registrado este acontecimiento
ramadán mubarak a todos y que dios
acepte sus buenas acciones
tradicionalmente muchos países
musulmanes han seguido las fechas del
ramadán establecidas por los sauditas
pero en los últimos años algunos han
usado sus propios cálculos como en omán
donde las autoridades dicen que el mes
sagrado comenzará el domingo para romper
el ayuno los musulmanes se reúnen con
amigos y familiares tras la puesta del
sol en torno a una gran comida en
vísperas del comienzo de la fiesta la
gente acude a los mercados para
abastecerse como aquí en marruecos o en
pakistán además de asegurarse de que sus
armarios están llenos muchos también se
preparan espiritualmente para el mes
sagrado
del ramadán es un mes de paciencia
debemos mantener nuestra moral y tratar
de ayudar a los demás tratar de ayudar y
alimentar a los pobres a los huérfanos a
los familiares y a otras personas garibo
por vacas
las oraciones del viernes previas al
ramadán tuvieron lugar en jerusalén en
medio de una ola de violencia entre
israelíes y palestinos no hubo
incidentes durante las oraciones pero el
viernes las fuerzas israelíes mataron a
disparos a un palestino durante
enfrentamientos en una ciudad de la
cisjordania ocupada hebrón